news contributor raymond arroyo raymond
the newly inaugurated biden
he sounded a lot like candidate biden
this week didn't he come on man
he's being consistent laura joe biden's
first remarks on his first full day in
office were
well uh bidenesque
yesterday during my inaugural address i
offered a salient prayer
and of silent prayer the pandemically
the pandemic excuse me
it consists of my transitions teams the
task force tony fauci and the team
here today and other experts put this
plan together
it is so detailed it is over 100 198
pages
and and in complete detail what we're
going to do
we will make sure that science and
public health
scientists and public health experts
will speak directly to you wear a mask
no vaccines the fact is that the single
best thing we can do they're even more
important than the vaccines
now bear in mind laura this is with a
teleprompter okay
he's just as unsteady on his feet and
incapable of retaining
basic facts as he ever was and now this
was a covet event
so as you might expect masks came up
yesterday i signed an executive action
that requires
mass and social distancing on federal
property
only one problem laura he wasn't wearing
a mask there
and then the night before at the lincoln
memorial biden appeared
confused on federal property without a
mask
very sad well it's okay raymond because
biden's press secretary had a fabulous
explanation why weren't
president biden and all members of the
biden family masked
at all times on federal lands last night
he was
celebrating an evening of a historic day
in our country and i think we have big
bigger issues to to worry about at this
moment
in time
there you go if covet is allergic to
celebrating i hope we can have mardi
gras this year i mean you know okay good
but the good news laura is things are
getting back to normal
biden is confused again the elites are
making their own rules again
and you can just shut up again ain't
normal grand
the fact that it went off without a
hitch so perfectly produced
and so perfectly normal and beautiful
and american
that was what was so moving after four
years we had almost forgotten what
normal sound is like
and it wasn't like a boring normal it
was an amazing return to normalcy
an amazing normal or welcome to the old
normal
laura ingram where the media fawns
heavily edits the candidate of their
choice
and miss serves and disserves the public
they're here
to give information to and to challenge
the people we elect
they are integral to this republic and
and they've fallen down on their
responsibility this is not
okay raymond raymond you're being very
harsh i'm feeling the harshness come
across the
the teleprompter right at me and i would
just say
i look forward to the
day when joe biden emerges from the surf
let's say in rehoboth delaware with his
glistening pectoralis muscles as they
described obama
remember was obama in hawaii or was that
after the oil spill when he came out of
the surf
i can't remember but it was like his
glistening pecs and the
that might not be written about by the
press but who knows biden is
you know he's a fit senior so you know
he's got the aviators
what's really normal is the media's
default to gratuitous workshop
over-the-top praise for the
establishment or should i say
the justice league the site of
uh the clintons and the bushes and the
obamas
you know the the avengers you know sort
of the super marvel superheroes back up
there together
all in one place well with their friend
joe biden
it also felt like the avengers it felt
like we're being rescued from this
this craziness that we've all lived
through from the last four years and now
here are the superheroes to come and
save us all glorious
moment of fashion perfection side by
side with the former president
just like they just come straight from
wakanda
wait a second wait a second weren't
those weren't most of those same people
calling bush a war monger
and a dumb frat boy just i don't know 12
years ago
superhero